it's okay I'm here I'm here it's been a
while since you've had one of those
nightmares tell me what was it
about it's only
fragments nothing's
clear you've been fighting the hinin for
decades Lo
my family's been fighting them for
centuries your blood comes from Dukes
and great
houses here we're
equal what we do we do for the benefit
of
[Music]
all I'd very much like to be equal to
you maybe I'll show you the
[Music]
way
deal with this Prophet send assassins
fade rather he's
[Applause]
psychotic I see possible Futures all at
once and in so many Futures our enemies
Prevail but I do see a way there is a
narrow way
through
[Music]
my allegiance is to you do you believe
me this is a form of power that our
world has not yet seen the ultimate
[Music]
power I want you to know I will love you
as long as I
breathe you will never lose me as long
as you stay who you are consider what
you're about to do call a TR this
silence this prophecy is how they
enslave
us
D you are not prepar prep for what is to
[Music]
come